house compressed - Peter Pan will you
press the button that is the golden
question so many of you have suggested
that I would play this game and being
the number one [ __ ] on YouTube
obviously I'm gonna do it you brothers
can play along with this so let me know
your answers in the comments let's let's
figure out what's the best decision
number one I will become an immortal but
I can never move again I will not press
the mic 84 percent people did not yes
you and your lifetime crush are suddenly
naked together but it's in public hey no
problem here pressing the button fifty
fifty holy [ __ ]
your favorite team will win the
championship but you cannot watch or
listen or read about any of the games
well I couldn't care less about sports
so I will just click I will not click
the [ __ ] button 60 percent did not
whoa I'm in the majority in all of these
all right in the future
a heavily oppressive government takes
over the world I don't see a problem
here
you have the opportunity opportunity to
take it down but all technology fails
thrusting the world into dark age for
200 years
ah I don't want to [ __ ] with things
still a majority baby 50/50 [ __ ]
alright you get a free card but it's a
Honda Civic with a spoiler what is that
like a hated car or some [ __ ]
34% did not want a free car yeah [ __ ]
right I don't ever want to have the
reputation come owned a Honda you can
take your free car and just leave it
there cuz I will not have that you
become a fit your favorite superhero
Batman you have to listen to Nickelback
songs two hours a day
first of all people hate on Nickelback
just because they're overly popular
which I can relate to honestly
Nickelback it's not that bad you just
think they're bad because everyone hates
them
right however would I want to spend two
hours of my day listening to Nickelback
[ __ ] no so no I will not press the
button I like nickel plaque I still fail
to see where everyone hates them
I don't like superheroes superheroes you
will be able to turn into a person that
is 50 meters tall this is what is that a
good thing well lift the proportions you
have to take order for someone really
short I will not why would I want to be
50 meters tall every pain in the ass all
right you live forever but you survive
even when humanity and the world are
destroyed yeah that's what living
forever means right [ __ ] [ __ ] hell
what younger I'm just gonna float around
in space living forever it doesn't sound
very nice I'm gonna have to go no oh
well 5050 interesting what did you pick
you can grow a mustache that every women
find attractive hey hey I don't I don't
understand but it's made out of your
pubic hair I will not face hair
practically it's the same as pubic hair
anyway you have claws and skeleton like
Bulevar a badass okay count me intrigued
you can't control when your custom out
Eric effective you're just like super
bored nah not okay here here's the true
question unlimited eggs but you live
with howtobasic
I will press that button every day yeah
he can egg me any day am i right ladies
you are able to end all suffering but
nobody will remember you after seeing
you oh wow oh God
I feel like it's I have the chance here
to end all suffering but if nobody will
remember me after seeing me then I
practically don't exist I'll present the
true hero justice cause because it's the
right thing to do not not to get a hero
stamp you get your dream job is well
paying also for ten years do they
literally just describe my job but after
the ten years you have to work out your
worst nightmare job for ten years okay
well this sound this sounds like my life
so I'll take it okay evenly not okay
well alright then alright then thank you
very much thank you very much this is a
lot of fun I enjoyed this if you enjoyed
it as well go ahead and leave a like
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it and I will see Bros in the
next one let me know if you want to do
more of these comment if you press the
button once and
see Bruce and the next one stay us yeah
awesome yeah no tell me more please tell
me more about your daily exercise no
really I do care a lot about your diet
please tell me everything